this is working
I think your mic is I don't think it's
on here it's my computer's covering it I
was just going to not use it but maybe
it's not
submit that's not the right thing with
her over and I don't know why this isn't
10 somebody came in and I told him I
didn't need the microphone how do we
turn on the mic and then turn it off all
this looks complicated audio power
you just push
okay now that we've got the technical
matters under control thank you very
much Lisa I'm calm Pollard I'm Tina is a
graduate school and a professor of
biology I'd like to welcome you all to
our second of three company of scholars
lectures for this year there are seven
different periods of time David Evans
spoke first about the future of all the
contents on earth so he was projecting
it into the future at Gary Tomlinson
who's giving the third lecture on April
sixteenth will be speaking about a
million years of music here having
trouble hearing yeah let's see that
helped that better
well maybe then up stand below it's on
Lisa's it on back there okay maybe I'll
hover over I'm going to start over
because these guys are recording guys
okay go start over good afternoon
everybody I'm Thom Pollard Dean of the
Graduate School of Arts and Sciences i'm
also a biology professor we still
haven't solved all the technical
problems here this is the penalty we pay
for being on the world wide web now
we're going to start over for the third
time everybody ready hi I'm Tom Pollard
I'm a biology professor and dean of the
graduate school for instance I insist
this is the second of three company of
scholars lectures that we're having here
this year which are opportunities for
our leading faculty members to address a
general audience on their research
interests the first lecture was by David
Evans who vote on the future of the
positions of the continents on the face
of the earth so he was looking forward
in time the third lecture will be by
garlic Gary Tomlinson from the
department of music he's going to be
speaking about 1 million years of music
here on earth today's lecture is set
firmly in the present day in between
these two extremes Susan hide we will be
telling us about the impact of election
monitoring on the democratic process
Susan I grew up in Oregon and went to
Linfield College in Oregon which is near
Portland i discovered this afternoon she
graduated from Linfield in two thousand
and then went to UCSD in San Diego where
she received her PhD in political
science in 2006 on the basis of a
fabulous thesis she won a national award
called the one let's award from the
American political science association
for the best thesis of the year in the
United States
actually it was a two year period on
democracy in the same year two thousand
six she joined our faculty here in the
political political science department
as an assistant professor and I came to
know her in 2011 when she was reviewed
for a tenure and passed with flying
colors and I was really intrigued with
the fascinating work she was doing and
the fact she's here today is because of
what I learned so she's a tenured
tenured associate professor she's has
two books already one was an edited
volume with some colleagues on election
fraud and then has a book in 2011 from
Cornell University Press on election
observation which is the topic of her
talk this afternoon so we're going to
find out how election observation
impacts democracy Susan okay thank you
great you think I'll leave it I'm
normally pretty loud so I don't know if
I ok I'll leave the microphone on but my
students tell me I'm flexi loud so thank
you Dean Pollard earth tom has I've just
been corrected for the for the
introduction and especially for the for
the invitation to speak here today it's
been kind of fun to step take a step
back and think about not only my
research but the sort of broader area of
democracy promotion that I study in to
try to describe what I think's going on
for for a more general audience rather
than the pretty narrow audience of
political scientists that I mostly spend
my time talking to so today I'm going to
spend I'm going to discuss whether the
international practice of democracy
promotion actually promotes democracy
it's a tricky question for a number of
reasons which I'll talk about today I'm
going to use this lecture as a chance
not only to speak about what we have
already learned about democracy
promotion I think there's some
interference with the microphone I'm
reading on my my coat and so I'm going
to talk a little bit about what we've
already learned about democracy
promotion but I'm also going to
speculate on some issues associated with
evaluating this question of whether
democracy actually democracy promotion
actually promotes democracy on the
surface many people have concluded to
the answer to this question of whether
democracy promotion actually promotes
democracy is obviously yes there are
clearly more democracies in the world
today that in any other point in human
history freedom house one of the main
organizations that judges this sort of
thing has put the percentage of the
world's population living under either
free institutions or partly free
institutions at something close to
sixty-five percent and this increase in
the number of democracies in the world
is closely correlated with effort spent
on attempting to promote democracy yet
the answer to this question of whether
democracy promotion promotes democracy
is much more complicated as I'm going to
talk about today
rather than argue that the answer to my
question is either yes or no I'm going
to basically argue against anyone who
takes a black and white stand on this
issue I travel a fair bit part of it is
for work when I do I often end up
talking about my research to people that
I meet I often say that I study
democracy promotion and receive a number
of responses what one guy gentlemen
extraña plane told me a lot about how
Jesus was really into democracy
promotion which I didn't know but the
most common response that I get is
something like democracy promotion you
mean like Iraq this is what people think
of when they think now today in 2014 of
democracy promotion they mean the 2003
US invasion of Iraq and subsequent
efforts to promote democracy there some
of you today may have even had the same
reaction when when seeing the title of
the talk and deciding to come today
democracy promotion was at the time to
be sure in 2003 part of the rhetoric
used to justify the 2003 US invasion of
Iraq but for those of you who are paying
close attention at the time the rhetoric
about democracy promotion only popped up
after weapons of mass destruction did
not democracy promotion was used to help
sell the invasion after the original
justifications had failed to materialize
I could talk about this particular case
but perhaps obviously at least to some
of you 2003 was not the beginning of
democracy promotion by by any stretch
nor is it a representative case of
democracy promotion so I'm actually not
going to spend much time at all talking
about Iraq in 2003 and since then rather
I'm going to talk about the fact that
democracy promotion is something that
has existed for a long time and has been
a key component of the foreign policies
of most developed democracies today and
it's also support
for democracy and support for democracy
in other countries is a principle that
most countries in the world have signed
on to some of them insincerely but they
have signed on to through a variety of
international agreements or in a few
other forms democracy promotion only
rarely involves military force as I
heard in the Iraq case that so many
people are familiar with the broader
concept of democracy promotion can
include the actual or threatened use of
military force but much more commonly
includes rhetorical support for
democracy as a legitimate form of
government direct democracy assistance
international benefits such as foreign
aid that are conditioned on whether or
not a country is democratic in a number
of other ways in which outside actors
foreigners attempt to encourage
democracy often along with human rights
abroad it's a bit hard to pinpoint the
historical origins of democracy
promotion some people reference Thomas
Jefferson or even Napoleon of course
following the tragedies of world war one
Woodrow Wilson is credited with the
famous phrase of working to make the
world safe for democracy in popularizing
the idea of liberal internationalism the
current era of democracy promotion is
most commonly defined as beginning with
the end of World War two and the
creation of the Universal Declaration of
Human Rights as well as post-war
reconstruction efforts in Japan and
Germany since that time democracy
promotion has been closely associated
with US foreign policy but what is
somewhat less widely known is that most
countries in the world have agreed to
democratic principles and in many cases
actively engage in democracy promotion
beyond their borders this is not just a
u.s. project and like what what many
people think most developed democracies
so most European states north america
and in a few other countries include
some kind of democracy promotion program
explicitly within their foreign policy
and spend money
directly through international NGOs on a
variety of forms of democracy assistance
you've heard of some of these
intergovernmental organizations the
European Union the Organization for
Security and Cooperation in Europe the
Organization of American States and a
number of others now regularly engage in
democracy purpose so why why should we
care about this particular project this
particular idea of democracy promotion
and from a very general perspective I
think this idea is interesting because
in some ways it's bizarre that the
internal politics of a sovereign state
would be influenced by outsiders
particularly outsiders who are
themselves in favor of the idea of
popular sovereignty right who are
advocating sovereignty in their work
democracy often on paper is an entirely
domestic affair yet in the developing
countries in the world today
overwhelmingly it is not a domestic
affair in practice so another question
that we could ask and release in
relation to this is why foreign actors
bother to get involved in the domestic
affairs of sovereign states so why do
they devote all of this effort some
people estimate that it's you know it's
somewhere in the neighborhood of in the
tens of billions of dollars that are
spent on democracy assistance each year
and that's only including direct
democracy assistance so this is not a
small fraction of money arguments
explaining this effort explaining why
democracy promotion is a good i come
from really to two camps that i'm going
to talk a little bit about the first
justifies democracy promotion based on
national interest and the second
justifies democracy promotion based on
something like universal norms the first
argument or those who argue in favor of
promoting democracy abroad in the name
of national interest rely on a number of
self-interested claims that a given
democracy promoting country will have
better Foreign Relations
or be in a more advantageous position
globally if other countries in the world
are also democratic democracies are said
to be advantageous in a number of ways
that they're more reliable and
transparent international partners that
democracies are more likely to respect
human rights less likely to go to war
with one another as is shown by the
literature on Democratic peace that's
probably the most common argument
related to the national interest used to
justify democracy promotion and this
argument is also most commonly
associated with the foreign policy of
the United States but has been used by a
number of governments to justify
spending on democracy promotion efforts
or to justify their actions that they're
taking within other sovereign states the
second argument having to do with
universal norms that is most commonly
used to justify or explain democracy
promotion efforts is really based on the
notion that if given a choice and all
held equal most people in the world
would rather live under democracy than
under authoritarianism this argument has
something to do with international norms
and this notion is enshrined in in
numerous international agreements in
international documents most famously in
article 21 of the Universal Declaration
of Human Rights so as article 21 states
everyone has the right to take part in
the government of his country directly
or through freely chosen representatives
everyone has the right of equal access
to public service in his country and the
most quoted part is this third provision
of article 21 the will of the people
shall be the basis of the authority of
government this will shall be expressed
in periodic and genuine elections which
shall be by universal and equal suffrage
and shall be held by secret vote or by
equivalent free voting procedures so
based on in part on the Universal
Declaration of Human Rights and on other
similar international commitments that
have been signed
almost all states in the world the
notion that popular sovereignty can
sometimes trump state sovereignty has
gained quite a bit of traction and
powerful states and intergovernmental
organizations have developed a variety
of policies and procedures aimed at
promoting democracy within sovereign
states so I want to push back a little
bit further on the 2003 Iraq example
that I hear from so many people now
today when I'm talking about democracy
promotion because many of these people
see democracy promotion as something
that George W Bush invented and and I
want to make clear that democracy and
democracy promotion has has really been
a mainstay of the US presidency for most
of the period since the end of World War
two and has been relatively consistent
across Democratic and Republican
administrations so just relatively
briefly to go through some examples from
each of these presidents in a march 1961
speech Kennedy said that democracy is
the destiny of humanity and it is the
United States's obligation to serve as a
single largest counter to the
adversaries of freedom Jimmy Carter in
1977 said that because we are free we
can never be indifferent to the fate of
freedom elsewhere Ronald Reagan in a
widely cited address to the British
Parliament that led to the establishment
of the National Endowment for democracy
said that we must be staunch in our
conviction that freedom is not the sole
prerogative of a lucky few but the
inalienable and universal right of all
human beings and that it would be a
cultural condensation or worse to say
that any people prefer dictatorship to
democracy beginning with George HW Bush
the link between us security and
democracy became much more overt in
these statements from US presidents with
with Bush arguing George HW Bush arguing
that the community of democratic nations
is more robust now than ever and it will
gain strength as it grows
importantly he said that abandonment of
the worldwide democratic revolution
could be disastrous for American
security so again making this argument
related to the national interest of the
United States and democracy promotion
Bill Clinton continued with this type of
argument in 1993 stating that the United
States is overriding purpose must be to
expand and strengthen the world's
community of market-based democracies
George W Bush of course in 2005 said
that it is the policy of the United
States to seek and support the growth of
Democratic movements and institutions in
every nation and culture with the
ultimate goal of ending tyranny in our
world and finally addressing an audience
in Cairo Obama said that even the
controversy over democracy promotion
generated by the Iraq war and here i
quote does not lessen my commitment to
governments that reflect the will of the
people and that such governments are
ultimately more stable more successful
and more secure so a lot of these
arguments from these people are
combining the universal norms and
national interest arguments right but
all of them are getting to some kind of
agreement that democracy promotion
should be a rightful part of u.s.
foreign policy also to be clear the
arguments in favor of democracy
promotion are not at all that democracy
is without any flaws or is in any way a
perfect form of government a lot of
people arguing against democracy
promotion point out flaws with democracy
in order to make their case but but
those advocating for democracy I don't
think any of them are under the
impression that democracy is a flawless
form of government but on average if not
more generally they argue that democracy
has some advantages over the
alternatives such as personal asst
dictatorship monarchy to totalitarianism
and the like I wanted to quote Yale's
most famous theorists of democracy very
briefly regarding the virtues of
democracy over other regime types Robert
Dahl has said or has written
democracy helps prevent rule by cruel
and vicious autocrats guarantee citizens
a set of fundamental rights ensures a
broader range of personal freedoms helps
people protect their own fundamental
interests provides the maximum
opportunity for self-determination the
freedom to live under laws of one's
choosing of one's own choosing provides
a maximum opportunity for the exercise
of moral responsibility encourages human
development fosters a relatively high
degree of political equality promotes
peace as modern representative
democracies do not fight one another and
generates prosperity some of these
claims of course can be contested and
there are perhaps some exceptions to the
rule that most people prefer a democracy
most of the time I hear people bringing
these up quite a bit when I go around
and talk about my research boutons happy
happy Kingdom where they measure not
gross domestic product but gross
domestic happiness is one example that
I've heard Singapore comes up all of the
time as an example of authoritarian
success although it's interesting here
at Yale what I'm teaching students from
Singapore I've had to explain a couple
of times more than once that Singapore
is in fact not considered a democracy
despite what they learned in school
there and China's economic success
continues to emerge as the clearest
threat to the universe music to the
universality of democracy I want to talk
a little bit more about later in the
talk although it's important to note
that the Chinese continue to make it
clear that their example cannot be
replicated in other countries right so
they do not believe that the Chinese
example is something that can be
imitated the Chinese government has also
been claiming periodically for quite
some time at least as I as I read it
that they are moving gradually towards
democracy in their in their own time and
of their
inform so despite these counter-examples
cases like Boutin singapore and china
the most vigorous defenders of
authoritarian regimes are usually the
individuals who benefit
disproportionately from them so those
defending autocracy defending
authoritarianism tend to be those
leaders who are able to stay in power
for the remainder of their lives the
Friends of kleptocrats and the small
circle of individuals who typically
benefit from authoritarian governments
rarely in human history have we seen
examples of people amassing in the
streets and risking their lives to
demand a return to authoritarian rule
what we instead see is most often the
opposite Nobel prize-winning economist
Amartya Sen has written that the single
most important event that occurred in
the 20th century was the emergence of
democracy as the pre-eminently
acceptable form of governance so thus
when asking why democracy promotion
exists in why countries and
international organizations bother to
expend so much time effort and money on
foreign policy in this area one runs
into both of these arguments first that
the devoting effort to promoting
democracy abroad can be in a country's
national interest and that promoting
democracy can also be justified on moral
or normative grounds Madeleine Albright
is often quoted in relation to this idea
I think she's actually repeated the
statement a number of times so I don't
even know the first time that she said
it but she says in relation to democracy
promotion it is not only the right thing
to do it is the smart thing to do right
so it's something that is in the US
interest and in other countries interest
but also is morally the right thing to
do of course in addition to these two
motives there are also some actors or
some of the actors some of the time
potentially including the Bush
administration in Iraq who use the
rhetoric of
see promotion to cover basically as
window dressing for other aims right to
cover for less publicly acceptable
objectives we see this quite often
democracy promotion is tends to be an
allowable form of foreign intervention
and many other types of foreign
intervention are not considered to be
allowable forms of foreign intervention
I think it's also worth noting that on
the ground it's it's nearly impossible
to separate the varying justifications
for democracy promotion once
policymakers reach agreement that
democracy should be promoted in a given
year or by a given population money gets
allocated towards democracy promotion
and the why of democracy promotion is no
longer part of the conversation this
matters to me at least and I'll return
to this point again because promoting
democracy in order to protect human
rights or to decrease poverty and
inequality might lead to different
program choices in different strategies
then if a country was engaged in
democracy promotion with the goal of
making countries more likely to follow
through with their international
commitments or to be less likely to go
to war with a democracy promotion
country they don't necessarily prescribe
the same set of democracy promotion
activities and this is something that's
really left out of the debate okay so
just to expand a tiny bit on the
question for the for the day what have
been the consequences of this widespread
effort by many countries in the world to
encourage democracy within other
sovereign states given that democracy
promotion is a rich I'm sorry democracy
itself as a rich and varied concept what
is it exactly that all these foreigners
are changing in the world what sort of
things move when when they push on when
they push do their efforts have
unintended consequences i think the
unintended consequences of democracy
promotion are pretty poorly understood
how might we know the answers to these
questions and why is this set of
questions so vexing to answer
all of the questions I just listed are
often answered by assumption by people
who are more or less ideological in
their approach to this topic for those
of you who are interested in partisan
politics in the United States democracy
promotion is this funny area where
neoconservatives see eye-to-eye on a lot
of areas with the liberal
internationalists and they're not
normally on the same part of the of the
political spectrum among promote those
people who support democracy promotion
if they often assume that that good
intentions are sufficient to have good
effects so if countries international
organizations and international NGOs are
genuinely trying to promote democracy
then they probably are so so the logic
goes among some people that I've talked
to it's also sometimes measured in
dollars spent right so if you've spent
ten million dollars on democracy
assistance and you've probably had about
that much positive effect right that's
the way that the analysis is structured
among people who are skeptical of
democracy promotion the answer to my
question does democracy promote
democracy is always know regardless of
really any evidence or examples to the
contrary charges of imperialism are very
common amongst this group of people and
the arguments tend to be tend to be
quite normative neither side even today
has much high quality evidence at their
disposal and this is an area where a
number of scholars including the work
that I have been working or that I have
done have tried to move this debate
along okay before I get much further and
really start talking about why I think
this question is so difficult to answer
I wanted to spend a tiny bit of time
talking about what it is that democracy
promotion consists of what democracy
promoters actually do on the ground
there are lots of organizations engaged
in democracy promotion these are just
this is just like the organizations that
I can think of off the top of my head
while I was watching college basketball
the other night right so this is just a
small sampling of the organizations that
are involved in democracy promotion
these organizations carry out hundreds
maybe even thousands of different
programmatic programmatic activities
each year intended to promote democracy
at the very so there are things that
they do on the ground part of democracy
promotion also includes at the very
highest level they've already referenced
rhetorical commitments to democracy and
those rhetorical commitments by powerful
states are combined with a forum policy
that sets a variety of costs and
benefits conditioned on whether a
country or government behaves
appropriately these rhetorical claims
from powerful states and from
international organizations include that
they will support domestic movements in
favor of democracy or claims that
democracy is the preferred form of
government and its trading partners for
foreign investors and the like so a
country that's not already democratic
could reasonably start to expect that
they would be better off if they
democratised in terms of the
international benefits that would flow
into their country we also see that when
a country has done something to provoke
international sanctions or other
international isolation the path back to
normal normal bilateral relations with a
number of countries typically involves
the holding of new elections so these
are really sometimes incentives for
countries to try to democratize on their
own and these high-level rhetorical
commitments to democracy don't
necessarily involve any direct
intervention any actual presence of
foreigners setting foot inside the
country more narrowly and on the ground
democracy promotion and democracy
assistance include lots and lots of more
targeted targeted activities I'm going
to talk about just a smattering of them
but my summary is not going to be
comprehensive one of the most well-known
is international election observer
so some of you may recognize this woman
observing an election and in 1996 I
believe in Indonesia international
election observation is one of the most
well-known types of democracy promotion
but also includes funding for domestic
election or citizen election observation
international and domestic election
observers are supposed to detect
election fraud deter election fraud and
improve voter confidence in the
electoral process they also use their
reports as a way to help international
and domestic actors judge whether a
given election was meeting expectations
whether that election was democratic
whether it was more fraudulent than
anticipated and these reports can have a
number of effects that I have looked at
in my research and a number of other
scholars have also have also looked at
overall international observers can help
do not always help but can help increase
incentives for governments to hold more
democratic elections there are many many
other activities direct election
assistance and technical support are
often provided by the United Nations
electoral assistance division in the
UNDP other intergovernmental
organizations will pay for things
related to election assistance these
activities are explicitly nonpartisan
and can involve direct collaboration
with electoral management organizations
one of the things they might try to do
when I initially saw this picture I
thought that this was like a sign of
people coming out and really showing
their support for democracy that this
was this powerful image of the demand
for democracy when in fact someone has
later told me that this is really a
picture of administrative failure right
that poorly organized elections are the
only ones that can ever get lines this
long on Election Day and one of the
things that international actors do is
try to help countries get the technical
aspects right to make sure that they
have a number of polling stations and
the right number of places that the
ballot materials are designed properly
delivered in
in an efficient manner and and that all
of the materials that they need are
actually distributed international
actors are also often involved in oh so
in one of the things international
actors do is that they buy ballot boxes
as I've traveled for a lot of elections
I've noticed that more and more all of
the ballot boxes look exactly like these
right so there's some vendor out there
that's winning all of the contracts with
the UN I think two by two by ballot
boxes but these also have a technology
of securing the ballot boxes is supposed
to be hard to tamper with and they buy
or train people how to use the famous
indelible ink that's used to guard
against multiple voting I don't
particularly think that indelible ink
works very well but it makes a good
photo opportunity on the on Election Day
they also set up a lot of trainings for
election officials or help a country
organize its own trainings for election
officials they can oversee or set up the
updating of a voter registration list or
help countries develop a process for
updating their own voter registration
list and you know to at a more at a
bigger picture level or this is one
thing they can help produce materials
like this where they basically just help
a country come up with these little
cartoons about how the electoral process
is supposed to go on election day so
there's tons and tons and tons of these
that have happened over over the last
say 25 years so sometimes international
actors are involved in in helping
rewrite election laws and providing
expertise in constitutional changes that
are intended to bring about more
inclusive politics and and this sort of
thing voter education came campaigns are
very widespread so if you're traveling
around in a country during an election
you'll see signs like this many of these
are paid for or encouraged by
international actors engaged in
democracy promotion you'll also see
these sorts of things so here it slow
more clear this is paid for nigeria by
ndi usaid and and the British aid agency
says no to ballot box snatching do not
sell your voters card no to rigging your
vote is your right to do not sell your
vote vote wisely so these sorts of voter
education campaigns take place in most
of the countries that I've worked and
write these are these are very
widespread and they're often carried out
by multiple organizations in the same
country at the at the same time there's
activities related to parliamentary
development and this is a little bit
harder to sum up but these can include
exchanges of parliamentarians in the
staff of Parliament's between countries
they often include the the sort of
improvements to the nuts and bolts of
how legislative bodies are supposed to
function sometimes they actually by the
the desks in a parliament and this kind
of thing and they can they can train
train people about different voting
procedures and record-keeping and
writing legislation and all this sort of
sort of stuff democracy promotion also
very commonly includes a lot of
political party training activities so
most programs offer assistance to all
parties that want it it's not that they
go in and say we're only going to train
the parties that we like the best they
say we're offering political party
training to everyone some parties
refused to participate but it's made
available to everyone some organizations
pay directly for public opinion polling
in a country that doesn't already have
it they pay directly for for this
polling make it available to the public
on the assumption that more information
about candidates popularity might lead
parties to make better decisions and
some organizations pay for I believe
this is in Cambodia these are candidate
debates right so the country wouldn't
necessarily have multi-party debates in
advance of elections because of the work
of one of the
international NGOs it's active in
Cambodia they have candidate debates all
over all over the country all right
sometimes they go as far as as trying to
adopt are trying to encourage parties to
adopt specific strategies so in a lot of
new democracies or countries that are
new to holding elections they'll be 172
political parties one incumbent
political party and 171 opposition
political parties and so one of the
things democracy promoters will try to
do is they will try to get them to
coordinate right to to form some sort of
coalition in order to have a better
chance of winning some sort of
meaningful representation at the at the
international level all right democracy
promotion occasionally bleeds into other
issue areas I was trying to think of
some good examples many of these
examples are closely tied to greater
protection of human rights training
police in the military in specific forms
of policing and crowd control during
political events is one example so you
wouldn't think that police training is
necessarily a democracy promotion but I
have seen this happen in a couple of
places where they're trying to get the
police to better engage with what can be
somewhat exciting political events and
and keep the calm and keep people from
from hurting one another the final
category that I actually don't know that
much about because it's very ambiguous
to me is that a lot of money goes to
promoting what's called civil society
right so this is sort of this catch-all
category that they spend a lot of money
on I don't really know what it is in
some countries but if you have an NGO
you can get money that's devoted to
civil society promotion all right so now
I'm going to get to the part of the talk
that I am actually most excited about so
those of you that already know about
democracy promotion everything was
probably just a review I'm going to
raise a few issues related to why I
think it is so difficult for us to know
to answer this question about whether
democracy promotion actually promotes
democracy this question is difficult to
answer for reasons related to unintended
consequences of democracy promotion
perhaps a contested understanding of
causality and a lack of consensus about
what it means for democratization to
have occurred so I'm going to illustrate
this basic point about why this question
is so difficult to answer with with four
points first of all it is unambiguously
the case at least in my opinion the
international support for
democratization and the existence of all
of these benefits at the international
level that are tied to country is
becoming more democratic is partly
responsible for the massive
proliferation of countries that hold
periodic national elections and that
also adopt a number of other formal
institutions associated with democracy
so let me be clear this does not mean
that all election holding countries in
the world are democratic in fact I think
this is one of the one of the most tired
phrases in the field of democracy
promotion and one that regularly makes
me want to tear my hair out is when
people say that democracy is more than
elections politicians love to use this
phrase as applause line as an applause
line I just noticed today that when
Barack Obama used this line in his Cairo
speech he said elections alone do not
make true democracy one audience member
was moved to interrupt him and shout
Barack Obama we love you which would
make me crazy right because no one as
far as I have been ever I've ever been
able to uncover has ever said that all a
country needs to do to become a
democracy is to hold an election maybe a
fraudulent election right no one makes
this argument no one has ever made this
argument that I can find and so this is
why I find it frustrating when academic
articles conclude with this this grand
statement that elections are not all
there is to democracy or that democracy
is more than elections but it's it's now
a platitude that politicians really like
to like to reference but even given my
frustration about this one small point
it is now true that of sovereign states
with a population over 500,000 which is
a common threshold that we use in
international relations elections in a
variety of other democratic institutions
are nearly universal and we are only
beginning to understand that
consequences of this trend so I I've
made this very rough animation of the
global spread of elections on it on a
world map that I before I show it i want
to just warn you just a little bit
because all of it is imposed on a 2013
map so it's the quickest way I could do
it a couple of days ago was to use a map
that the borders don't change over time
so you have to excuse that countries
that don't exist yet are shown in yellow
right then become countries by 2013 and
from what I'm about to show you you
couldn't see the year will be at the top
countries that are colored in very light
gray our countries that have held
elections in the prior five years
countries that are black or very dark
colored have never held a national
election or have not held an election in
the previous tenure so I can see if I
can make this go so you can see the year
this ha and then you watch the trend
over time there's a lot of countries
that go dark for a while and then and
then the trend reverses itself so as
you'll eventually see while you're
watching this the only countries that as
of 2012 when is when these data stop
that had not held national elections in
the previous 10 years which is a pretty
long interval to expect elections to
happen are China eritrea Qatar Saudi
Arabia Somalia and the United Arab
Emirates so if you're weren't counting
that's 66 countries in the world did not
hold national level elections in the
period from 2002 2003 to 2012 I I think
that just by itself is a kind of
remarkable trend the
this is something that has almost
completely disappeared right so we watch
this I don't know I have two thousand to
it and there something got out of order
but by the end of this there's only six
countries in the world that had not held
national elections and five of those
don't hold any national elections
through this entire time period so why
is this trend not necessarily good news
for the spread of democratization so I
mean pretty obviously some of these
elections are not exercises in democracy
for those of you who are noticed I know
there's a lot of errors in this map and
if any graduate students in the room
would like to help me make it better I
would love to work with you on a little
bit of math units not my specialty many
of these elections are not are not
democratic at all so North Korea holds
elections periodically no one is under
the impression that under the impression
that their democratic right it's one
hundred percent turned out a hundred
percent of it's a little bit less but
they actually explained and some of
their state-run press releases how they
go and get the enfermo tanned how they
get elderly people to vote from from
hospitals and whatnot so some of the
elections as many of you know are used
as tools of authoritarian control
elections not just in North Korea but
also countries like Belarus or
Turkmenistan if we put those elections
aside and instead focus on those that do
allow some real multi-party competition
there are still some very interesting
dynamics that make it difficult to judge
the overall effects of this trend in
which elections have spread throughout
the entire world within elections the
most obvious dynamic that I think is it
is interesting is that all of this
intention sorry intense attention to
Election Day both in getting the
technical aspects right so some of the
things that I showed you pictures of
making sure you have ballot boxes with
the right secure tamper proof technology
but also in sending lots of domestic
international observe
vers has has made it significantly more
difficult to manipulate an election on
Election Day and get away with it so
some leaders manipulate elections
obviously on-purpose activities like
ballot box davida stuffing and over
vote-buying right things that would use
to happen pretty obviously on Election
Day coercive control of polling stations
by police or military other types of
Election Day shenanigans are now very
difficult to get away with right so you
might commit them but you're almost
certain to be caught what I think this
has resulted in is is a more widespread
recognition that there are many ways to
manipulate elections or to bias
elections in favor of one party and
greater attention to Election Day has
led some governments to engage in what I
have referred to with co-authors as
strategic manipulation so this is
engaging in precisely those types of
election manipulation that are less
likely to get caught does this result in
better elections those spread of
strategic manipulation does this make
elections better I don't know and
they're very frustrated by the question
it is clear that some of the techniques
are more benign than Election Day fraud
right so if a government getting gauges
and say more negative campaigning or
gerrymandering or something like this
that's probably more benign than
Election Day ballot box stuffing or
something like this but other forms of
strategic manipulation like murder
disappearance or intimidation of
opposition political candidates well
before Election Day in a subtle manner
that is never caught are not so benign
and may be much greater threats to
democracy than ballot box stuffing ever
was right it's very difficult to judge
this the claim that a focus on clean
elections may increase incentives for
less visible forms of election
manipulation is an extraordinarily
difficult claim to evaluate
if regimes are truly good at
manipulating election strategically
there will be little evidence that we
can ever uncover of this occurring and
scholars will have a hard time
distinguishing between elections that
were clean and elections that were
manipulated and this makes it very
difficult to judge as my colleague
nickel I'm Aronov has put it whether the
global spread of elections is in fact
good for democracy what is clear to me
is that the simple act of holding
national elections can itself be
unpredictable it is a little bit more
risky for incumbents even those
autocrats that are pretty good at
manipulating elections in their favor it
actually might be risky to them as well
and may be harder for autocrats to stage
manage these electoral processes then it
may seem at first blush just the simple
fact of holding elections even the very
very rigged elections that are that are
making an appearance on this figure may
introduce much greater uncertainty to a
leaders ability to stay in power than
would exist if they didn't hold
elections at all so just that I think is
good news for democracy but it's a
little bit tricky the second reason why
it's difficult to judge whether
democracy promotion actually promotes
democracy really builds on the first so
if there is international pressure and
I'm going to turn this off here in favor
or put it this way if there is
international pressure in favor of
democracy or all of these democracy
contingent benefits that I talked about
earlier this should create very strong
incentives for countries to look and act
like democracies even if they have no
intention to truly democratize refusing
to play the game of adopting formal
electoral processes and democratic
political institution in the past 25
years or so would put a country squarely
in the camp of a group of pariah states
really these international benefits tied
to democracy may push some countries
towards further democratization it might
be the nudge that they need
but it's also relatively clear that the
same incentives motivate a subset of
leaders to fake it in other words they
seek to look and act like a democracy in
order to receive international benefits
or at least create some plausible
deniability and evade internationally
and post costs but these leaders are
never really willing to step down if
they were to lose in elections right so
they're playing the game but they're
unwilling to abide by the rules if the
rules don't end up favouring them so
democracy promotion may be contributing
to an increase in the number of true
democracies in the world this is
possible but it may also simultaneously
be contributing to the number to an
increase in the number of pseudo
democracies of countries that adopt
democratic institutions but are not may
not be democratizing in any meaningful
sense and this is something that I've
spent a lot of time thinking about I
think is fascinating the third reason
why it's difficult to answer questions
about about the efficacy of democracy
promotion is that the formal
institutions of democracy are sometimes
adopted in the hope that they will solve
a whole bunch of other social and
economic problems as in the Robert Dahl
quote that I outlined earlier democracy
is associated with a long list of
positive side effects that have been
uncovered in the in relation to
countries that are already democratic
basically these lists of positive
effects of democracy were developed
based on Western Europe and North
America it is possible that societies
that democratize 50 or 100 years ago
wherever you want to pin it are
fundamentally different from those
countries in the world that have not yet
democratized and when democratic
political institutions are extended to
countries in these different
circumstances it's not clear that the
introduction of democratic political
institutions will result in the same
positive outcomes so democracy as a
means to other ends may fail even if the
end
democracy has achieved and this failure
of democracy to achieve all of these
other goals may be used to pronounce
democracy promotion of failure I realize
this is a little bit of a complicated
point and so another way to put it some
examples to it even if democracy
promoters successfully helped
democratize many countries in the near
future democratic institutions may not
cause these countries to become less war
prone right this might not be the case
that the Democratic peace continues to
hold might not cause these countries to
become better trading partners might not
cause these countries to better respect
rule of law and human rights become
better climates for investment decreased
poverty and inequality or choose better
leaders or any there's a whole bunch of
other things so we could talk about part
of the problem is that we don't know how
long democratization should take if a
country has a lot of initial challenges
to overcome when democratizing you know
many of today's wealthy democracies
democratization took place over decades
and generations how long should
democratization take in a country like
the Democratic Republic of Congo kind of
a lot of challenges to overcome before
fully functioning democracy won't be in
place in Azerbaijan and Cambodia
countries that have very different
challenges so this lesson that
democratic institutions are not a silver
bullet for all of a society's problems
is is something that we continue to
learn again and again it's like a lesson
that people have a hard time accepting
in the long term and it really gets us
back to this question of why democracy
was being promoted in the first place if
democracy is and end into it in and of
itself then the side effects of
democracy don't matter if democracy is
promoted because of other strategic aims
related to the national interest type
argument that I outlined earlier then
these questions actually matter a lot
and may need to be better integrated on
the ground with how how democracy
promotion programs are carried out
the final reason that I'll just
referenced very briefly because it's
kind of it's kind of wonky but it's very
near and dear to social scientists is
just this notion of causal inference so
as I've already mentioned it's
absolutely clear that there are more
democracies today than there have ever
been before and that this massive
increase in the percent of the world's
population living under democracy did
happen concurrently with a massive
increase in democracy promotion effort
partly related related to the three
other reasons I've just cited but also
due to a number of other factors we
cannot say with any confidence or at
least I cannot stay with any confidence
that this massive increase in the number
of democracies in the world was caused
by democracy promotion untangling this
knot of causality is much more
challenging than showing that these
things go together and it's something
that I and others will continue to spend
a lot of time on there are a number of
exciting studies that are really on the
cutting edge of research on this topic
that begin to do exactly this and they
show that sometimes democracy promotion
programs work as intended and sometimes
they do not right we're only beginning
to evaluate some of these questions the
next challenge is to tie these very
specific studies to some more general
theory of democracy promotion that
considers the other three points I've
just raised so really to conclude the
talk I'm going to engage in a tiny bit
of speculation I normally avoid talking
about you know my own predictions for
the future but I I've been told that's
not very fun and so I'm going to just
spend a tiny bit of time talking about
about the future of democracy promotion
so overall it's pretty cool you know
mildly confident the democracy promotion
has at least on the margins contributed
to democratization in in some places if
not in many places countries that are
not already democratic can be pushed on
the
path toward democratization by
international actions sometimes through
direct intervention sometimes through
the demonstration of what works and
sometimes through these international
incentives for democratization some
democratization today may be insincere
or Hollow and I think this is a major
area of research set that more needs to
be done on it is remarkable to me today
that most countries of the world are
already holding periodic national
elections most of those countries now
allow multi-party competition even if it
is maybe not a totally level playing
field and and another thing that we have
seen is that there's few places left in
the world where scholars or pundits
continue to argue that a certain type of
people is not fit for democracy as mr
TSN has discussed at length it's all so
clear to me that the easy cases of
democratization have already happened
the country's left in the world that
haven't yet democratized faced some
pretty serious challenges so this makes
it quite difficult to speculate on the
future of democracy promotion I think
it's fair to say that lessening
international pressure for democracy as
I think has has already happened a bit
in the past eight years or perhaps even
dating back to this 2003 Iraq case
should mean that fewer leaders expose
themselves to the risks associated with
adopting formal democratic institutions
if international support for democracy
declines dramatically we should see a
reversal of many of the trends that I've
talked about today and there might even
already be a little bit of evidence of
this so this flat between 2003 and 2013
the same freedom
they should be for show in fact a slight
decline in the percentage of democracies
in the world or because percentage of
free countries in the world one of the
biggest factors that will contribute to
the future of democracy promotion and
could contribute to a dramatic decrease
in international support for democracy
is the rise of China as an alternative
source of foreign support for many
countries in the world so it's not clear
to me how this will play out but it is
already apparent that chiney China's
influence in Africa Southeast Asia and
elsewhere has made a number of countries
less dependent on Western support and
therefore less likely to be influenced
by Western international pressure in
favour of democracy a counter trend was
made clear with the beginning of the
Arab Spring the Arab Spring also
surprised many of the more pessimistic
pundits some of whom had decided that
democracy is somehow undesired by Arab
people or that is fundamentally
incompatible with the type of Islam that
exists in Arab countries the apparent
wellspring of demand for democracy and
the Arab world is notable other than
China this is really this was until they
are obscure bring really the last part
of the world where you would still hear
people genuinely arguing that certain
populations weren't cut out for
democracy that they couldn't they
couldn't handle it or something like
that which I think it's clear that
that's that's not the case for the US
and other Western countries the Arab
Spring yet again brings up tensions
between democracy promotion and other
strategic goals in foreign policy like
supporting allies and encouraging
stability democracy promotion has never
and will never Trump all other strategic
aims and foreign policy if anything it's
a third or fourth or fifth tier goal of
foreign policy maybe even further down
the list this leads to charges of
hypocrisy in foreign policy and often
causes attention in foreign policy and
decision making between what our law
basically long and short term goals
related
democracy promotion so judging tomorrow
whether the US will be better off with a
loyal dictator in power in an allied
country or functioning democracy even if
that democracy sometimes the Lexx
leaders that are not necessarily closely
aligned with us interests is a very
difficult question to answer I tend to
think that support for autocrats and an
unwillingness to put up with
democratically elected leaders who are
not necessarily allies is short-sighted
but but many many people disagree with
me on that point with that I'm going to
stop I think I've gone a bit over time
and I will open it up for questions okay
yeah
is it possible that it might
so repeating the question yes briefly
the question is really whether pseudo
democracy and in the increase in pseudo
democracy throughout the world might in
the end be worse for democracy than if
those countries continued as autocracies
and you know could it lead people to
view democracy differently I think that
there are some people who have written
on this the people who are the worst
opinions of democracy are people who
live in democracies which is an
interesting public comparative public
opinion finding that's not universally
true but pretty much on average debt
that's what that what's that's what we
see the way that I've put your question
before is whether pseudo democracy is
I'm going to get in trouble using this
example with with some of the people in
the room here but whether you're
basically making soups uber autocrats
right who are sort of akin to these
antibiotic resistant bacteria right that
they get so good at playing this
international game that there's nothing
that can ever happen to take them out of
power it's very hard to separate that
from countries that are are moving
towards democracy and are on the cusp of
democratizing there is some evidence to
suggest that just holding elections even
bad elections in countries that held
elections under autocracy are more
likely to successfully democratize so we
do know some things like that but to say
that you know gosh Ava's and you know
had no negative effect on on democracy
in Venezuela you know it's a really hard
question to answer because we never get
to observe that counterfactual right we
never get to see to see what's happening
but so I think it's an open question is
some of these leaders are probably
coming much more entrenched in power and
much better at playing this game evading
international sanction
yes
the other words the failure of the
communist socialist
so you know this talk is short for a
general audience it's hard to sum up
everything that I know about democracy
promotion this time we were right I
didn't talk about that the way that I
think about it is that during the Cold
War period especially there were a
number of countries I'm sorry I didn't
repeat the question I didn't talk about
I have to do this for the recording
since you don't have a microphone that
the economic dimensions were less left
out of my talk and that part of the
story is about a failure of communism
rather than a success of democracy and
some of these trends are related to that
I think that's absolutely the case
during the Cold War period what I talk
about in a lot of my research is that
this is a time in which countries did
face multiple options and one of the
reasons why democracy promotion took off
so strongly beginning in you know the
late 80s Early 90s is because even
Western democracies like the US were no
longer propping up anti communist
dictators right so that this game was
taken off the value of that country's
could take advantage of for being simply
anti-communist was taken off the table
and so countries had to do something
else in order taking those those
international benefits so that somebody
talked quite a bit about and in what my
book but it's also really apparent in
the trends over time so most of anything
you can look at it it's sort of
gradually increasing from nineteen forty
five to 99 and then there's a huge step
function change in what's going on so
that's a good point it's just something
I didn't cover
it seems to me that reliance
mm-hmm
so the question is whether there's any
global level data on the distribution of
funds two different types of
programmatic activities in the democracy
promotion field I believe that the a
data project is working on this but it's
hard because you have to trust that the
a organizations appropriately cat or
categorize things in their in their
project codes and they like to double
count things so international election
observation is probably counted as
support for women's representation or
something like that right because they
think it has all of these positive side
effects so I've never seen anything that
I believe on that election observation
you know it people pay attention on
election day so I think it's the extent
that you care about these reputational
effects at the international level it
may be the most motivating to autocratic
leaders to try to move in the right
direction but in terms of affecting
people directly there's a ton of other
programs that that are probably more
effective at that and so but we have we
have very little ability to even make
those types of judgments given the
evidence that we have some
I'm sorry I'm
yeah so I think um the question is thank
you that anti-terrorism the question is
is anti terram is a replacement for
anti-communism that where the US and
other Western governments are now
willing to funnel a lot of money to
undesirable anti terrorist countries or
countries that cooperate on anti
terrorist activities you know in the
same way that we funneled a lot of money
to undesirable dictators during the Cold
War simply because they were
anti-communist I think probably but i
think that we have had quite enough time
for me to judge it i've seen a couple of
of PhD students working on questions
related to this and then i know you're
the bangladesh expert but i did go there
recently the organization that we were
hoping to work with is a is a
well-respected human rights group there
and they they made the mistake of
counting the number of dead protesters
that were potentially killed by
government forces they put a number on
the protesters and and within not very
great amount of time the government
disappeared many of the people involved
in this organization wrote two million
people they've now reappeared but it's a
pretty difficult thing so a question is
why is bangladesh this very a dependent
country all of a sudden willing to start
disappearing human rights activists
right i think it's because the dead
protesters as they counted happened to
be more fundamentalist Muslims right and
that they thought they could get away
with it having something to do with this
their cooperation on anti-terror policy
so you see these little examples popping
up all over the place but do we have any
systematic evidence of this yet I I
don't personally I think some people are
researching this and you know I'd like
to see more of it my intuition would be
yes it's almost exactly like like
anti-communism although it's a little
bit less clear which governments count
as the good guys in which governments
count as the bad guys
so my thoughts on the influence of
international sanctions on sooner
democracies so the political science
international relations literature on
and international sanctions is quite
pessimistic on anyone right there's not
a lot of evidence that suggests that
they're they're particularly effective
most of the time but that said I tend to
think that some governments are
responsive to being named and shamed
there's some governments that know that
they're really important and can get
away with anything so I think Mubarak
Egypt's fell into that category right I
think he sort of knew that he could get
away with quite a bit and took advantage
of it what wouldn't have been super
influenced by the threat of sanctions
and and I think there's other countries
that seem to be quite influenced by by
sanctions right that they can actually
lose most of their budget budget if they
end up being sanctioned and so you
actually never see them step over the
line too far these are the countries
that are easiest to get to move towards
democracy so there's a lot of selection
problems and answering your question but
I think it's not implausible that
governments that would otherwise be
pretty autocratic are influenced by some
of these incentives for them to be more
more democratic all day so before you
all get up I want to do three things
first I want to thank Susan for a
splendid talk it was very interesting
thank you very much secondly I want to
invite you to our reception where Susan
will come and you can ask for some more
questions it's just next door here in
the common room and third i want to
invite you to return here on April
sixteenth to hear Gary Tomlinson from
the Department of Music in the
humanities center about the history of
music here on earth see you then or see
you at the reception